You are listening to radio lab radio from W N Y.
S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
I found out, you know what,
will you forgive me if I actually leave my phone on vibrate because, uh,
my wife is pregnant and do literally really any day. Oh my God,
no kidding. If this vibrates, I might ruin your radio program. No, it's fine.
It's all worse. So recently I had a conversation with this Guy Josh for yeah,
he's a journalist science journalist and he told me about something that's been
obsessing him recently. This very odd experiment. Well, okay, so this is,
uh, one of the longest running science experiments of all time.
The Pitch Tropics here and you can actually see it online. How do I get to it?
I just started for pitch drop pitch draft. All right.
So when you go to this website, what you really see is, uh,
this funnel with some black stuff in it and then a descending from the stem of
the funnel is this little tendrils of this black stuff. And at the end of that,
tendril is a little pure drop of this black stuff. That's,
it doesn't move, do anything.
But according to Josh, sure a pitch drop junkies all over the world.
People who are just have got this open in the background on their,
on their web browser and he says they all just sit there watching and waiting.
And that's the thing. Once you understand what's going on here,
you Kinda can't look away. Okay.
So here's what happened in 1927 there is this guy, Thomas Darnell,
who is teaching physics at the University of Queensland and currently in
Australia. And he's trying to show his students that, um,
well I guess that things aren't always what they seem. Okay. Uh,
and so he takes a chunk of this material called pitch. What's pitch? Okay,
so pitch is a natural substance. In fact, this is actually really the question.
What is pitch? Well, what does it look like? It's like, uh, is it gooey? No,
that's the thing. It's like a rock.
You can break it with a hammer and it shatters into a million little pieces,
but it's not a rock.
It's a visco elastic polymer of fisco elastic Palmer,
which means that over many, many, many, many years,
it moves really well.
What he did was he melted a handful of pitch and poured it into a glass funnel,
and once it had properly settled,
he snipped the bottom of the funnel and waited
for what? Well, for it to drip.
[inaudible]
you mean drip like a faucet would drip? Yeah, but much, much more slowly.
So 1930 Goodo is discovered,
Bonnie and Clyde mean phone love going to crimes where you get killed by the
police. 31 the empire state building is finished. Okay.
1933 the Nazis build their first concentration camp. Prohibition ends.
It still hasn't drifted. E Five Amelia Earhart by solo across the [inaudible].
Are you kidding? No. Drip it.
36 5 million barrels of cement turning to the Hoover dam. No,
for eight years. This rock is slowly, slowly,
slowly stretching into this dangling drop. And then suddenly one day,
eight years after he poured the damn thing into the funnel and the 10th of a
second, the blink of an eye.
Oh, treat the pitch breaks. Now,
nobody's ever actually seen this happen. I mean it's never,
there's drop has never dripped. No, no.
The drop is dripped eight times and we're all due for the ninth drop to happen
any day now. So wait, why haven't they seen it? So imagine a science experiment,
right?
Where the critical data that you want to gather happens in one 10th of a second
every 10 to 12 years.
It's really hard to be there at that critical moment. Yes.
Yeah. There's a master, this fellow professor John Mainstem,
he's been watching it religiously since January of 1961 for 50 years.
Oh,
I'm still waiting to see this pitch drop just at a suspense or is there some
question here? Well, first of all, doing well. Okay.
The question is at that moment when you this ever elongating droplet,
keep his way,
what happens if you've got the drop itself who owned by four little fibers,
call them fibers? What breaks first? How does it break?
And there are lots of people who like me waiting to see whether we can capture
that moment and see the way in which from a mechanical point of view,
it becomes imperative that the dropped in fall.
So 1962 mainstay and Mr drop-ins 62 August,
1970 missed that one. April of 1979 one he looked at on a Friday,
knew it was close and sought. Well, something might happen over the weekend.
Came in on a Saturday, Saturday evening, checked to pitch job,
nothing happening. I'm going home.
And by the time I came in very early on the Monday morning,
not having gone in on Sunday, it had fallen.
Then 1988 he standing right there and I decided I need to cover t or something
like that. Walked away, came back, oh no.
And low and behold he thinks he may have missed it by as little as 15 minutes
had dropped. Now you take your tee and throw it against the wall and rage.
Well, yes.
One becomes a bit philosophical about this and I'm just,
oh well let's be patient.
The next time he installed a camera and and then and then 28 November,
2000 is what happened.
Then the time I was over on the other side of the world in London gets an email
saying professor this drop looking as though it might fall any time.
We've been waiting 10 years for this. It's about to happen.
Cause it was like I said, don't worry, we've got it covered. Got a camera on it.
I'll be able to see exactly what happened when I get back to Australia.
The next email said, well it's dropped
later that day. Do you have professor mains? Then I've got bad news.
Unfortunately you will not be able to see this because the system failed.
The camera went out, the camera went out.
We don't have this on record gum on.
That was one of my satisfying moments I might say.
But right now the pitch is getting ready to give birth to another drop and this
time there are three cameras,
three webcams on there and this is what Josh was showing me on the Internet.
This Dang Ling little,
almost that all is people are watching people from China, South America.
You knew what people were helping the north of Canada. Everybody's waiting.
Everybody wants to be the person who sees the pitch fo
[inaudible]
and I've got to admit I've been checking this thing online.
[inaudible] really like were you like watching grass grow? I don't know. It's,
I think it's more than suspense. I think that this is,
it's about timescale is what it's about.
We don't really have that many opportunities to interact with things that happen
on these two very, very different timescales simultaneously.
Huh? You see what he means? Yeah. Cause you know you,
you're in this funny situation,
you wait slower than you know how for something to take place that's faster than
you can, you know, catch. Exactly.
So you're playing at the very edges of what you know how to do,
but not if you catch it, then you get this glimpse
into this world that's usually unknowable. Exactly.
So for the next hour we're gonna mess around with this idea. Cause you know,
we're humans, we live in a human scale, but we've got a bunch of stories, right?
We're going to ask us to stretch that scale to the breaking point. Yeah,
I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich today on radio lab speed way.
Things keep getting faster and then faster again,
and then faster and faster and faster and faster and faster and faster and
faster and faster until we get to the fastest thing in the universe and stop it.
Okay, so let's set the baselines here. How fast are are we?
You mean like how fast we run? I mean,
how fast do we interact with the world around us? How fast do we taste things?
How fast do we feel something? See something respond. Okay. Hello? Oh, hello.
Hi there. Hey, how do we sound? That sounds better. Much better. Excellent.
That's Carl Zimmer of course, science writer regularly around here.
And he told us that question you just asked. How fast do people,
humans process the world?
That question popped up in a really big way around 1850 with the invention of
the telegraph because suddenly you could send a message across the country
almost instantly.
If you're in New York and you want to send a message to Chicago,
all the money stopped.
It's going to take about a quarter of a second for that message to get their
rubbish. That's 790 miles in a quarter second.
Now that's really fast. Thank you.
If you do the math 790 times,
four times 60 times 60 it's 11 million miles an hour.
That's amazingly fast. So fast.
In fact that some people when they first used the telegraph,
they just refuse to believe that it was real.
Cause in 1850 you're doing oh 35 40 miles an hour on a horse.
60 maybe on a steam engine up to 80 you're not living too fast.
But more importantly for our story, the Telegraph got people thinking about us,
about our bodies, right?
Cause you know nerves and telegraph wires are remarkably similar.
Nerves are long and skinny. They carry electricity from one place to another,
just like a telegraph wires. So naturally people wanted to know, well,
if telegraph wires can do millions of miles an hour, well what about our nerves?
How fast are they? Exactly.
And so one day a German guy biologist named Herman von Helmholtz took a frog
cause their neurons are kind of like ours. And basically what he did was he,
he hooked some wires up to one of the frogs muscles. Now this was,
I should tell you I did frog,
but he sent an electrical jolt through the muscle and then using a very fancy
timer,
he was able to determine that the signal was going down the length of the, uh,
frog muscle at a speed of 27 meters per second.
What does that in miles per hour meters per se. Um, let's see. I can,
uh, Google, actually it's, I love Google. Um,
27 meters per second is 60.39, seven, three miles per hour.
16.3 miles per hour. We, this is a frog.
Is this the same speed when us, yes. 60 miles an hour. That seems so slow.
Yeah. What's the name of the Jamaican runner? The fastest guy in the world.
Usain bolt. Hussein bolt.
So it was saying bolt is running at half the speed of his nervous system. Okay.
But better than bare mind actually. I mean, uh,
there's a big range of speeds of your neurons and actually Hussein bolt is much
faster than some of your neurons.
I mean there's some neurons that only go about a mile an hour.
Which ones are those? Ironically,
some of them are from the reward centers of your brain.
Chocolate travels slowly. Yeah, relatively slowly.
What about the pain that that would be fast. I imagined. Yeah, you'd think so.
But pain actually runs kind of slowly. I am surprised to learn.
He says it can be as slow as 1.3 miles and hour. Wait a second.
So if I put my hand near a candle and then I go, ouch.
Shouldn't that happen very fast? Look, I mean if you were like 70 miles tall,
this might be a problem. Okay. But still, I mean,
what if we just take a really ordinary example like Robert Looking at the desk
in front of him and grabbing that pen? What's involved? Well,
I mean you just essentially need to kind of walk through this brain.
You start at the I, okay. So, uh,
the eye takes the light that's reflected off the pen,
turns it into a little electrical signal and then sends that deep into the
middle of the brain, takes a a couple of hundred 72nd bounces around for a bit,
and then within few more, hundreds of a second, the signal has made it
all the way back to the rear end of the brain where you start processing
[inaudible]
envision.
But this is just the beginning right now you've gotta like figure out what
you're seeing. So our joke is off again,
this time toward the middle of the brain and then down toward the bottom to
these other regions that start to decode the signal,
the first visual regions called V1 next up,
v to before four and so on. And they're going to sharpen the image,
make out contrast edges,
and then electricity goes back towards the front of the brain
after, let's see, another 10th of a second or so,
we finally get to a place where we think,
oh, that's a pen we haven't gotten yet too.
I want it exactly
for that to happen.
Electricity has to jump from one part of the front of the brain to another and
another before you can finally say, that's a nice pen. I could use a pen
and we're still not done, you know, then then, then
little jolt heads, Norris, you start at the top of your brain. So we've,
we've gone from the, your eyes to the back of your brain are around,
up to the front of your brain again.
And now we're up to the top of your head where you set up motor commands
and then you can grab the pen. Christ.
So I mean you add all this up and what are we talking about here?
About a quarter of a second quarter of a say feels like one month later,
rubber town begin slowly to move to the objectives. Design a quarter of a say.
So that's the same amount of time.
It takes a telegraph to send a message from New York to Chicago. Yeah.
So your ID, your hand, New York, Chicago. Oh Man.
The sad truth has Carl, is that our neurons,
when it comes to communicating and and sending signals on your answer,
they're terrible actually. I mean compared to our, you know, broadband networks,
particularly because when one neuron bumps into the next one,
there's actually a little space between them. So the signal to get across,
it's got it
jump
and then jump to the next one and jump and then jumped.
It's kind of like doing hurdles. It's not smooth.
And the spooky part about this slowness says Carl,
the deeper thought here is that if you think about it,
because we have this built in delay in processing the outside world,
everything that I'm experiencing already happened.
You know how like you look out at the stars and you think, oh,
that light's been traveling for thousands, millions of years to get to me.
And what's happening on that star to the planet around that star right now does
even still exist. You can say that about everything around you
because
I mean by the time that you become aware of something in front of you,
it's been sitting there for awhile, relatively speaking.
I'm stuck in the past, but it's a,
it sounds like if you want to be in the moment,
then what you do is you stare up as a sun and you let the light just be light
entering your eyes and you don't think anything about the light.
You don't try and comprehend the light.
You just let the light be light and that's as close as you're going to get to
now. Yeah. Well you're looking at old light. Uh, but yeah, that's good.
It's eight minutes old cause I'm a star. Like even if you switch, you know,
even if you switch on the light and you're looking at the light bulb across the
room, it's old light because it had to go from your eyes,
through your brain to you to be aware that there was light there.
So what I would suggest is that you close your eyes and you stop thinking about,
you know,
the chair you're sitting in and just focus on your own thoughts because that's
the fastest stuff you've got. It's, it's right there.
You don't have to wait for it to be delivered into your brain.
It's already in your brain.
So I think your thoughts are the fastest things that you can experience.
So my fastest thought that I could ever have is okay, where I'm my key.
You've got to have faster thoughts than that. What's the faster one?
This is an interesting question though. I think it would be non narrative.
I don't think it can be a keys or something. I think it would just be like a,
someone has thought about this. What? It wasn't me cause I'd have no idea.
Don't you think somebody has an answer for us on this? Uh, hello. Hello?
Hello somebody somewhere. I'm here. In fact, we found a guy, oh wait,
are we recording right now? We are, yeah. His name is Seth Horowitz. I'm the,
uh, he's a neuroscientist, author of universal sense.
How hearing shapes the mind. So we were talking, uh, with,
and we ran set through the question, you know,
if we're all trapped in the past by the slowness of our nervous system,
what would be the most present the most in the now that we could be if you have
any actually disagreed with Carl's gas? He said,
even if you think the simplest thought that it is possible to think it's
probably still going to be on the order of a quarter of a second half second.
Oh Man. You have to get away from the conscious brain. No thinking,
no seeing hearing is the fastest sense because mechanical,
it normally operates on the millisecond range. Thousands of a second, Huh?
A sudden loud noise activates a very specialized circuit from your ear to your
spinal neurons. You mean it bypasses the brain? Yeah, it's the startle circuit.
If you suddenly hear a loud noise within 50 milliseconds,
it's 50,007 seconds. So you're talking 20 times faster than cognition,
your body jumps, we'll begin the release of adrenaline.
No consciousness involved. It's five neurons and it takes 50 milliseconds,
50 milliseconds. So you're already getting into a faster,
much faster paradigm by using sound,
so if we're going to jilt ourselves as close to the president as possible,
then we'd have to play a really loud noise. Right? Like
wait for it.
I know that was annoying. I'm no, I know, but look, thing we do,
we just did together. We were all in the moment, in the present tense together,
not quite, not as we now understand it.
We were just shy just to get itsy bits shy of the moment. No time.
If I spoke fast enough for me to say thank you to crowd Zimmer,
they could've said hardwoods and now I've got be.
There's no way you could even form the theft. Thank you and 50 milliseconds,
but I tell you what, in this next, in this next segment,
we're going to make 50 milliseconds feel like 50 years. Oh, that's a really,
really nice promo there. That'll make everybody lean in.
That's actually a terrible like there.
We will amaze you by slowing down time so that you will find a millisecond
generous Jay. You will be, you'll surprise yourself in all kinds of ways.
If you just stay listening to this program, believe me right in there. We know.
Good Save.